but let's get back to a star is born my
favorite topic because today was the UK
premiere and Gaga definitely it's got
into the Royals beard I love it
I'm so humbled to be here alongside
Bradley Cooper vaga went for these sexy
Victorian vibe is she hit the red carpet
in London but get this the dress is five
years old
it's from the Alexander McQueen 2013
collection Gaga has been working her arm
pose that every carpet so far hands on
the hips arms floating up to her side
the kits and this the hams to the chest
you like me you really like me move oh
and Bradley mr. blue eyed handsome
himself he's nothing short of perfect
[Music]
the to release their duet shallow today
and we still can't get over the fact
that that is Bradley's own voice as for
gaga or she stopped by Ellen and dropped
a few confessions what is your favorite
body part knows who was your first
celebrity crush Adrien Brody what do you
sleep in at night
nothing me too
of course there's already ginormous
Oscar buzz where a stars born so we
wanted to know what's next
there has to be 10 more Lady Gaga
Bradley Cooper films yeah actually took
dog on Bradley
three years to make a stars born
[Music]
[Applause]